quatre invités à présent sur ce plateau
Frédéric ibarard bonsoir responsable
prévention addiction au centre
hospitalier Charco à Plaisir mareline
Bréand marchessau bonsoir vous êtes
directrice de l'Institut de prévention
de la santé c'est à trap Christine Camu
addictologue du centre hospitalier de
Versailles et Stéphanie Lafond à
rapenouille vous êtes psychologue sur
l'établissement psychiatre psychiatre
pardon sur l'établissement Charco à
Plaisir prévenir des risques du cannabis
c'est l'objectif que vous vous êtes fixé
avec ces différentes structures ce matin
une réunion était ouverte aux
professionnels soignants et scolaires
c'était au Centre communautaire à trappe
sous l'impulsion de l'hôpital Charco
c'est vous qui l'avez décidé pourquoi ce
rendez-vous ouvert aux professionnels
c'est pour apprendre à à mieux
communiquer ensuite à mieux réagir face
à ces difficultés alors pourquoi ce
questionnement c'est parce que bon c'est
vrai que souvent les infirmières
scolaires entreutes des lycées des
collèges sont souvent seuls face à un
jeune qui consomme du cannabis c'est
difficile pour elle de savoir vers où
l'orienter à quel moment détecter si un
jeune à fumer du cannabis ou pas et
aujourd'hui notre objectif premier
c'était de rassembler différents
intervenants de diverses horizons hein
des médecins didictologues généralistes
des psychiatres des psychologues et
surtout de les rassembler pour à la
rencontre de différents professionnels
de la ville nouvelle qui s'est élargi
finalement à tous les ivelines avec des
gens qui sont venus aussi bien
travailleurs sociaux infirmiers
scolaires médecins scolaires des gens
aussi du conseil général h et notre
objectif a été largement atteint nous
semble-t-il malgré le froid la neige
beaucoup de gens sont venus
professionnels de la santé sont venus
nombreux professionels de santé et aussi
des des des sociaux hein beaucoup
d'éducateurs voilà donc non non un large
panel est venu à l'IPS justement on
parlait de l'agglomération de de 50 an
de l'ancienne ville nouvelle sur
l'agglomération sur l'IPS vous vous êtes
confronté à ces problèmes justement de
la difficulté de savoir comment réagir
face à ces jeunes qui consomment du
cannabis alors à l'IPS il y a des
structures telles que le lieu etcoup de
jeune et le xapa qui sont donc deux
organismes en fait qui permettent
justement de de recevoir les jeunes en
difficulté
avec un comportement addictif et de
recevoir également les parents qui
peuvent ne pas savoir où repérer ou
s'ils ont repéré comment accompagner
leurs enfant leurs adolescents vers vers
une structure et ils peuvent venir sur
sur l'IPS rencontrer anonymement au
départ donc soit leolier coup de jeune
soit donc le xapa et nous avons
également d'autres structures he teles
que l'UNA femme qui peut également avoir
cette possibilité d'aide alors là plus
vers des des des jeunes qui ont
également des difficultés avec des
troubles mentaux et donc des
consommations par ailleurs donc voilà
sur l'IPS il y a plusieurs structures
qui peuvent en effet recevoir à la fois
les jeunes et les parents et aussi les
professionnels puisque nous sommes
amenés à à mettre en place de nombreuses
réunions partenariales d'informations
des sessions d'information pour pour ces
professionnels là et c'est vrai qu'avec
Charco nous avions donc décidé de faire
quelque chose qui était local pour donc
au départ hein c'était la ville nouvelle
faut être clair alors je dis ville
nouvelle en fait c'est sur tout le
territoire de 50 an yeline la communauté
d'aglomération de 50 en yvline et en
fait on a dépassé amplement puisqu'on a
atteint je pense le sud Yveline voire
même
le av des gens qui venaent de MTH qui
venaient de rbouiller et là ces
structures vont fonctionner en réseau
ensuite vous gardez un justement oui
bien sûr c'est au niveau de l'académie
de Versailles et du rectorat de
Versailles pour une fois c'était la
première fois qu'on proposait une
journée comme ça avec justement aussi
bien des conférence que les ateliers
rélection et c'est eux-mêmes qui nous
ont demandé de pouvoir inscrire leurs
professionnels les professionnels du
conseil général également hein les les
les personnels à la fois les médecins
les travailleurs sociaux et les
éducateurs également de de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance qui sont qui se sont
qui sont venus vraiment
avec des attentes en fait hein et qui
ont je crois dans les ateliers beaucoup
euh beaucoup échangé avec avec vous si
vous êtes mobilisé justement c'est qu'il
y a une réelle difficulté et des
chiffres peut peut-être les mentionner
les jeunes Français qui sont parmi les
plus gros consommateurs de cannabis en
Europe ce qui est pas le cas pour
l'alcool ou c'est plutôt dans dans la
moyenne c'est une déclaration de la
directrice de l'Observatoire français
des drogues et des toxicomaniies
aujourd'hui en France clairement le
cannabis ne fait plus peur votre regard
par exemple le cannabis est encore
malheureusement relativement banalisé
euh se cache souvent derrière la
cigarette dont on connaît peut-être un
peu mieux les risques que ceux
spécifiques au cannabis notamment les
jeunes qui banalisent vraiment or il y a
des véritables risques sur la santé qui
peuvent être assez rapides lors de
consommation aigu voire occasionnelle
festive et qui ne nécessite pas comme
les autres drogues légal le tabac et
l'alcool forcément une consommation sur
la durée il peut y avoir des risques
assez aigu 39 % des jeunes Français de
15 à 16 ans ont déjà fumé du cannabis en
2012 ils ne sont que 19 9 % du côté de
l'Allemagne 25 % au Royaume-Uni comment
on peut expliquer cette situation en
France par rapport au reste des pays
européens la France est quand même je
pense un un plateau tournant au niveau
on est assez proche du Maroc hein qui
est une source d'approvisionnement
certaine et on est situé de façon
centrale dans l'Europe et donc ça ça
transite et ça s'arrête et donc il y a
une
forte une une grande facilité
d'accessibilité aux produits qui fait
que il y a une augmentation de la
consommation chez les jeunes et c'est un
produit de plus en plus nocif il y a une
évolution aussi dans dans le cannabis
dans les substances contenues oui hein
puisque ça les travaux le montrent le
cannabis qui est maintenant sur le
marché au pied de nos immeubles il est à
peu près 50ou 60 fois fois plus
concentré que celui qu'on qui était à la
disposition des personnes dans les
années 60 il est plus concentré en
substance dans la substance psychoactive
qu'on appelle le
tétrahydrocanabinol donc qui a donc un
effet plus puissant au niveau cérébral
et qui donc rend beaucoup plus dépendant
que le cannabis qui était fumé dans les
années 60 et vous les rencontrez ensuite
dans vos différence service combien de
de personnes vous suivez par exemple bah
c'est c'est c'est difficile parce que
bon j'ai pas les chiffres exacts mais on
suit beaucoup d'adolesc il y a une
progression il y a une progression et
surtout il y a une maintenant un
maintien de la consommation c'est-à-dire
qu'à l'âge adulte on pensait que c'était
une consommation très occasionnelle et
en fait on s'aperçoit qu'à l'âge adulte
elle persiste et qu'il y a un certain
nombre d'adultes bien insérés entre
guillemets mais qui ont cette
consommation et qui leur pose quand même
des problèmes de santé c'est plus une
consommation qu'on arrête puisqu'elle
rend de plus en plus dépendants à cause
de cette augmentation de concentration
de substances actives alors l'autre
chose l'autre réponse hein peut-être sur
qui qui pourrait expliquer pourquoi on
détient ce ce triste record en France
c'est que je pense que c'est un pays qui
banalise énormément la consommation avec
le débat par exemple de la légalisation
exactement pens que ça entretient cette
oui et qui a un doute hein et que très
clairement comme on a a banalisé la
consommation d'alcool pendant des années
et des années d'ailleurs les usagers
nous nous rapportent ça souvent vous
allez quand même pas m'embêter moi avec
mon joint allz plutôt chercher mon père
avec son pastisce mais c'est vraiment
une réponse du trèit quotidien or c'est
un produit qui a vraiment un potentiel
de dangerosité quelles conséquence
justement par exemple sur les troubles
psychologiques ou autres alors sur les
troubles psychologiques tout trouble
psychologique confondu hein c'est
maintenant prouvé que le cannabis peut
déclencher c'estd faire basculer un un
un un adolescent de quelqu'un qui aura
une vie comme la vôtre et la mienne
c'est normalement névrosée à quelque
chose qui est bien plus grave hein
puisque ça déclenche les troubles
psychiatriques les plus sévères je parle
de la schizophrénie et du trouble
bipolaire de l'humeur hein et et ça
augmente ce risque là et ça le fait
apparaître vraisemblablement chez des
jeunes qui l'auraient jamais eu quoi
est-ce que il y aura des interventions
qui seront organisées à destination
justement du du public à la suite des
différents rendez-vous entre
professionnels que vous avez pu
organiser je pense à l'IPS par exemple
onespère
oui je pense que on l'a vu enfin on l'a
entendu en tout cas de la part de Madame
Viala donc élu donc au niveau de la élu
santé à la communauté d'agglomération et
je crois qu'elle elle est vraiment elle
nous demande justement de continuer de
poursuivre ce travail partenariat que
bon que l'on mène déjà depuis de
nombreuses années hein sur sur 50 ans
neline mais là de de vraiment le
poursuivre et je pense de toute façon
avec le le le réseau de santé mental
également euh donc nous sur C1 en yeline
mais aussi sur pour vous plus largement
je suppose sur le sudivline donc il y
aura des actions entre professionnelles
des actions à destination également du
public juste pour conclure une toute
dernière question est-ce que comment
comment vous intervenez est-ce qu'on
peut guérir justement de cette
dépendance concrètement parce que vous
nous dites les troubles sont de plus en
plus forts par rapport aux années 60 par
exemple les substances sont de plus en
plus fortes mais pour autant est-ce
qu'on peut est-ce qu'on peut guérir de
cette dépendance alors on peut à tout
âge en tout cas essayer de sortir d'une
dépendance en guérir 100 % des
consommateurs ou des usagers ça me
semble
utopique mais il faut se faire
effectivement aider de professionnels de
santé et euh souvent c'est un sevrage
qui est plus ou moins long mais qui est
possible chez tout le monde mais après
tout le monde n'y parvient pas forcément
et ensuite ceux qui parviennent le
problème aussi ce sont les rechutes
contte tenu de l'accessibilité du
produit il ne suffit pas d'arrêter pour
sortir de la dépendance il faut aussi
maintenir cet arrêt et ne pas rechuter
ce qui est beaucoup plus difficileance
d'intervenir avant et de prévenir c'est
aussi le le but des différentes réunions
merci donc à toutes les quatre d'être
venu sur le plateau nous parlions si
vous venez de nous rejoindre dans le 78
du cannabis avec ses professionnels de
la santé dans le département des
ivelines qui s'organisent qui se
réunissent dans le cadre d'un réseau une
première réunion se tenait ce matin les
explication de Catherine zolato et puis
juste après comme chaque lundi le 78
sport le point complet sur l'actualité
sportive de cette dernières 48h le
comité prévention addiction existe
depuis une dizaine d'années au sein de
l'hôpital Charco à plaisir et depuis 2
ans un accent est mis sur la prévention
du cannabis jusqu'alors les réunions
étaient internes mais pour la première
fois une session d'information a été
ouverte à tous les plurdisciplines ire
que peuvent être les professionnels
soignants et les professionnels
scolaires elle s'est tenue au Centre
communautaire en tant que infirmier déjà
professionnel travaillant sur un CMP on
a repéré que beaucoup d'adolescents ont
des problématiques de consommation de
cannabis et que beaucoup de
d'intervenant scolaires ou soignants se
retrouve un petit peu seul dans les
prises en charge avec les adolescents
l'intérêt c'est avant tout de débattre
ensemble de la consommation du cannabis
et de la problématique du cannabis mais
aussi de créer des réseaux pour mieux
travailler ensemble chez les plus jeune
il y a beaucoup plus de jeunes qui prend
du cannabis aujourd'hui qu'il y a 10 ou
15 ans et d'autre part les produit le
cannabis est beaucoup plus concentré
aujourd'hui donc beaucoup
plus à des effets beaucoup plus fort
aujourd'hui que qu'il y a 10 ou 15 ans
dans les centres d'adidictologie une
très forte proportion de garçons neu
patients sur 10 c'est une pathologie
dont l'origine se situe dans le
développement euh difficile qu'à le
garçon de se dégager de la relation
qu'il a avec sa mère intervenir donc
avant la prise du produit car les
troubles psychiatriques liés au cannabis
sont réels c'est connu comme un produit
qui permet euh de déclencher euh
l'ensemble des troubles psychiatriques y
compris les plus graves hein euh bon les
troubles anxieux ça c'est certain la
dépression c'est certain le trouble
bipolaire de l'humeur euh est
certainement très aggravé et puis
surtout ce qui est tout à fait alarmant
le cannabis peut précipiter du côté de
la schizophrénie des jeunes qui a priori
auraient pu échapper à ce destinlà on
estime aujourd'hui que 6 adolescents sur
10 ont déjà fumé du cannabis numéro de
téléphone